hi if you're attending today you know a
little bit
about or at least have heard of exosomes
exosomes hold a lot of potential to
deepen our understanding of biology
cell communication and is looking to be
leveraged right now to improve human
health outcomes
my name is jim west ceo of clara biotech
and i'm going to spend the next 30
minutes talking with you about
exosomes what they are why they're
important
and tactically how do you access them to
start unlocking
their potential
today i'm going to break this down into
three categories we're going to talk
about exosome fundamentals
what are exosomes how do we define them
and
where do they come from then we're going
to break into
kind of isolation modalities and the
efficacy of them the pros and cons of
different methods and trade-offs
and then we're going to talk a little
bit about a product we've been
developing for a while
so let's first talk about exosomes and
subtypes
what are exosomes and water subtypes by
the end of this you'll understand how we
define them
and we'll talk about subtypes and what
they mean and how they're going to
impact research in the future
and how that subtype activity can affect
downstream work and analysis
so exosomes are created in the endosomal
pathway
specifically as opposed to
microparticles vesicles and apoptotic
bodies
come from a very special pathway
exosomes are functionalized with surface
marker proteins that they inherit from
the parent cell
these surface marker proteins are
numerous and measure in the hundreds or
higher
there we go exosomes are generally
recognized to be less than 200
nanometers in diameter
which does overlap with other particles
created in the body
the nobel prize was awarded in 2013 to
dr
james rothman randy sheckman and thomas
sudoff for their discoveries of
machinery regulating vesicle traffic
a major transport system in our cells
exosomes are a classification of
vesicles
and the very early work
exosomes were recognized to be a waste
disposal
mechanism from cells and it was only
recently in the last 10 years that we
really started to understand
the actual biological mechanisms and
that the function of these exosomes goes
so much further
exosomes act as a communication network
between cells
they exit cells that make them and they
inner cells are the same type
where they're able to cross the cell's
boundaries based on those protein
surface markers
and practically their endocytosis into
the recipient cells which are similar to
the host parent cells
so there has been some debate in
discussion over
how exosomes are actually defined
because of heterogeneity which i'll
cover later
there's a debate over the best way to
qualify them
exosomes have traditionally been based
on size partly because that's how we've
been able to isolate and characterize
them
based on the methods that have been
available you can see
in this chart there are a range of sizes
of particles in that same region which
are not
exosomes like micro vesicles apoptotic
bodies
and more this is important clearly there
are many other things at this size range
that overlap
and this causes noise confusion and
challenges in getting into the signals
which the exosomes contain
the takeaway is that size is not the
most important factor in classification
more important than size is the surface
markers
maybe they're more critical to really
understanding and determining exosome
populations and their subpopulations
so what makes an exosome
we believe that part of what makes an
exosome and exosome
are these functional surface markers and
its internal contents
which you can see here
exosomes as far as we know are made by
all cells
human plant and animal they contain
important markers
consisting of surface-bound proteins
from the cell but also
fragments of dna and rna like messenger
rna and microrna
the surface protein markers are the key
to cross other cells boundaries
we estimate there are nearly 1 000
exosomes to every cell
in the body and inside the exosomes
as you can see are the fragments of dna
and the rnas
on the surface of the proteins
surrounded by a lipid bilayer
there are hundreds of surface proteins
in the marker on the surface of these
exosomes
and they vary and with these exosomes
you can actually perform any type of
analysis you like including dna
sequencing elisa
rna sequencing like ngs next gen
sequencing
or proteomics
so let's talk about the endosomal
pathway
again exosomes are membrane bound
vesicles a lipid bilayer nanoparticle
and are small from 50 to 150 nanometers
in diameter
they do contain important tissues and
unique markers that have importance in
biomarker analysis
with great potential for future
diagnostic applications
what this all means is that the exosomes
are traceable to the cells they
originated from
as a doctor once told me exosomes are
the expressoms because they give you a
map
to the body it gives you a trace to
where they came from
and possibly where they're going
exosomes are perfect naturally derived
delivery platform
because exosomes contain a cellular
bi-lipid membrane layer they're very
stable in blood circulation
they are highly biocompatible they
are naturally found in all of our body
fluids and many tissues
because of their small size and because
they carry surfaces
receptors they have a much higher
penetration ability in crossing
difficult biological barriers such as
the blood-brain barrier
digestive tissue and more think about
that
if you were to drink a glass of milk in
a short period of time
we can detect cow milk exosomes in your
bloodstream
the cargoes inside of exosomes are
protected from degradation and release
instead they wait until they reach the
target tissue or cells of
biocompatibility
to deliver their specific cargo directly
to the cell of interest
this is a really unique way to deliver
targeted
nucleic acids anywhere in the body with
virtually
no toxicity as a poor analogy
exosomes act as a partial delivery
network from one location to another
in our natural systems let's stop before
we take the analogy too far
more recently what's now being looked
into is the heterogeneity
within which exosome i'm sorry the
heterogeneity within exosome
sub populations the variances
from exosomes within single cell sources
this becomes crucial when we start to
talk about
excuse me this becomes crucial when we
start to talk about our definition of an
exosome
as there is great variance within the
population even from single sources
like many things in biology it's not
optimized instead it's
noisy and robust because of this
heterogeneity
there's not just differences between
exosomes from a single cell source
but exosomes in a population we need to
go beyond size to truly understand what
we're dealing with
as you can see we have variance in size
distribution
the individual content of exosomes the
functionality of exosomes and
variance between the sources of cells
generating
exosomes size misses out on the range of
variance within these populations and
doesn't even begin to address
the other noise in the system what we're
saying is that content
from different parent cells will have
different molecular content and perform
different functions within the cell
different cell sources will produce
different types of exosomes
it's quite complex a better world
is one where we can get to the sub
populations of exosomes
differentiate between their properties
to be able to evaluate not just
subpopulations from a single cell
type but even sub populations within
that as an example
here's a comparison of 3d to do 2d
cell culture derived exosomes you can
see we actually cultured the same tumor
cell
in this case a cervical cancer in 2d and
3d cultures and then compared
microrna profiles secreted from the
exosomes
the 2d cell culture derived exosomes and
looking at the micro rna
we see a profile that's similar to the
2d cell culture cells
itself but it's completely different
from the 3d cultured rna
look at the highlighted boxes
look at the highlighted boxes showing
the difference in rna expression
this 3d culture derived profile is more
close to the in vivo tissue system
you can see this because we compared the
rna expression and it was the closest
we also validated the top micro rna
expression level
by rt pcr in the figure shown on the
right
our sequencing data conforms really well
with
uh with our sequencing data conforms
really well
which further validates our data and
that shows 3d production
stimulates production of exosomes
similar to the enviro system
now let's look at how production level
changes
here we have a comparison of xsm
production over time
what you notice is that the 2d cell life
cycle
is much shorter than 3d cultured cells
which live much longer
that timeline is extended it just goes
through these similar processes there's
the
accelerated degradation in 2d but as you
can see the expression rate of exosums
varies based on 2d versus 3d
the trend of 2d expression starts fast
and slows down as it ages over the life
of the cell
3d increases secretion over time
because cell communication is more
active and more exosomes secrete
along with proliferation the bottom
graph shows changes to exosome
morphology
or size and can be seen in both bottom
graphs
2d cultured exosomes show the size is
most abundant around 60 to 80 nanometers
and 3d cultured exosomes have the most
abundant size around 120 nanometers
the 3d derived exosome is more evenly
distributed
and the 2d exosome is wider with more
variants
these are really interesting images that
show the diverse morphology of exosomes
so we simplify exosomes in the
literature
as a spherical lipid nanoparticle
in reality the biology is slightly more
complex
if you look at the top row you can see
single exosomes
that's how we normally think of exosomes
however if you look at the second row
you see what they call
double exosomes double exosomes is
actually an exosome
inside of an exosome this is
this is very challenging to think of in
terms of size but
the the variance there is great they
even have what they call small double
the scale of these resolve the scale of
these
emission microscopes is at the 50
nanometer scale
and you can see that they're very very
small there's also oval shaped on the
bottom
and if you go to the right side you can
see even more variances you have tubules
long stretched out exosomes you have
incomplete exosomes which have been
damaged and degraded
and you also have sorry it's hard to
read
pleomorphic exosomes various sizes that
don't fit a general description
so while we idealize exosomes of
spherical lipids with bilayers the
reality is that exomes have a diverse
range of shapes and sizes
further complicating the story of size
filtration and size definition of
exosomes due to this known heterogeneity
within the shape
it's even more challenging to assume a
simple size definition
so now let's transition as we've talked
about exosomes and their subtypes
and we're going to start talking about
the traditional methods of isolating
exosomes
and how that can affect the downstream
processing
here's a high level overview of the ways
that you can isolate exosomes
today we need to come up with a better
isolation approach
in the top you have differential
centrifugation
and you have density gradient
centrifugation these are generally
achieved by ultrasonification in a long
and uh arduous isolation process you can
see the
the time scale in the graph here is
three to nine hours and uh
up to 90 hours we in practice have seen
people doing up to 24 hours
and it takes a lot of work it takes the
specialized ultra certification
equipment and the expertise to process
those
in addition uh the next methods that we
look at are based on
filtration so you have size exclusion
chromatography and you have ultra
filtration
these methods uh filter through based on
size so instead of density on the top
you now have size
to filter through membranes and size as
we've
discussed is is effective to get
exosomes but it's
not the most important and critical
parameter
on the bottom we have immunocapture
which is using immunomagnetic beads
with targeted antibodies attached to the
surface
and these antibodies will be able to
attach to the protein surface markers on
the exosomes
this is actually a method that's great
to get subtypes and pure exosomes
but once you've captured an x-sum with
this method it's attached to
a fixed to the bead and there is no
getting it off
uh the last method we can talk about is
precipitation
uh polymer precipitation where the
exosomes are bound
and uh precipitate out of the solution
ultra centrifugation also known as the
gold standard
is as we mentioned it's labor intensive
it's time consuming
and it has a number of challenges
reproducibility and repeatability is
difficult we know that the loss rate of
exosomes in this process
is high because over a
12 to 24 hour period or even less you
start getting degradation of the
exosomes
we also know that exosomes are very
sensitive to shear stresses while
they're robust in the body
systems they're very sensitive to shear
stresses and that shear stress that
that force over time they actually have
data that will show you these exosomes
uh will become flattened so their
morphology
functionally changes the low recovery
rate
the loss rate and the noise that comes
along with these processes
has a number of challenges but they do
get exosomes and it was
how the it was the first method that
came along for purification
polymer precipitation as you can see
here
uh there's a number of products that do
this uh these exosomes are
bound to the polymer and you can see
that they're kind of uh if you think of
the exosomes as marbles
in a solution the polymer wraps them in
a bag
so you can get them they can be used for
certain diagnostic purposes
but they are functionally changed and
they're bound
it's a tedious process it's not good for
scaling up or doing
a large volume of processing but it is
effective for getting
exosomes isolated additionally with the
other things at this size range that
come along
size exclusion chromatography has really
been breaking out in terms of
manufacturing and production
because you can isolate exosomes without
the shear stresses induced by
ultracentrification
and you get a high recovery rate but you
also co-purify with the other membrane
vesicles
and other things like chromatin cell
free dna ectosomes
viruses all come along at these size
ranges
and while these methods work
they are also time consuming
and material consuming
and you know bead capture as i mentioned
you start with a bead solution as shown
in the
orange and these beads uh attached with
uh surface marked antibodies
are able to capture exosomes in the
solution once mixed
using a magnet which the beads have an
iron core
you can capture the beads together wash
the contaminants away
and you're left with a solution of beads
and uh isolated contaminants
or noise that's washed away this allows
you to subtype
you can do a capture of
using the antibodies on the surface you
can tune them to what you want
if you're looking for a specific type of
cancer exosomes you could
conjugate an epcam or other cancer
specific antibody to the surface
if you're trying to do broad capture
there's a tetraspanning
you can use for that commonly cd9 63 and
81 are used but there's other
combinations
also available to achieve that goal and
once these exomes have been captured
you can lies the surface to release them
for sequencing but again
once they're bound there's there's no
getting them off
so when we talk about the importance of
subtyping for research
there's really only one technique and
solution
which allows you to get to the to the
subtypes
of the exosome populations and you want
to be cautious
in your downstream isolation steps it's
critical
if you don't do it right you're going to
get misleading results that don't give
you what you expect and can mess up your
test
it's really important that as the
industry progresses that we're able to
settle
on a repeatable consistent protocol for
exosome isolation
this doesn't really exist today subtypes
are an emerging area of focus that are
going to have large implications in the
future
and research activities around this
should not be ignored it should be
considered
isolation should not be considered
lightly you must take account
of your experience of your lab personnel
the availability of equipment
and the downstream work that you
specifically want to do
your characterization needs and
ultimately what the purpose of this
research activity is
now before we wrap this up i'd like to
show you some of the stuff we've been
developing at clara biotech which i'm
pretty excited about
so at clara biotech we've developed
an iterative step a new paradigm if you
will in exosome isolation
so we are actually based on the
immunocapture technology
but what we've developed is the next
stage of production
that allows for the release of exosomes
from those bound beads
it's a non-chemical photo release
process so just like beads we mix the
samples with our bead technology to
capture the exosomes to the surface of
these
functionalized beads using targeted
antibodies
these beads are isolated with a magnet
just like amino capture
and we separate the impurities from the
bound beads
but then as you look to the right we
have a photo release step
now this photo release step is fairly
short
it's less than 15 minutes and in this
time
we're able to detach the exosomes from
the bead and since they're still
magnetized we can actually isolate pure
exosomes
from the beads and this opens up a new
way
to do characterization and analysis
along with subtyping and it gives you
pure exosomes
without the noise
this is a chart called an nta nano
tracking analysis this is a
commonly used characterization of
exosome purity and quality
and as you can see here on the x-axis we
have
size in nanometers from zero to a
thousand in this case
and on the y-axis we have concentration
or number of exosomes
per sample now what i want you to see is
that we have a
very narrow uh band
around 100 to 300 nanometers showing
the uh concentration of particles when
you when you look at
other methods you see a much larger
noise around this sort of bell curve
if you will here's here's another view
to something like that and you can see
that
the size distribution is in this case
i believe this is from a 2d cell culture
media
but but you can see that the the size
range is smaller
and you have a high high peaks
around 100 and 200 nanometers
this this method uh when compared to
ultra centrifugation in this example as
you can see here
uh gives you a more pure result
so in this case i'm actually comparing
uh our exo release technology on the
left
with ultra centrifugation on the right
column the the dashed lines is ultra
centrifugation the solid lines is the
clara exo release technology again
bounded in a smaller region around the
exosome window because we're capturing
functional exosomes as opposed to the
full
the full spectrum and there's about five
times
more uh i'm sorry there's in this case
ten times more material captured
in the ultra centrifugation process but
you can see how much
wider that noise is produced
in that system
this is a another sort of a breakdown
of how the technology compares across
the board
and i'll let you guys analyze that on
your own but for
by doing biomarker analysis all
technologies can get you there although
getting to the right data can be
challenging
uh this is a picture showing our exo
release
speeds with captured exosomes on the
surface prior to release
and you can see the density each of
those arrows points to an
exosome on the surface of the bead
we have a really high capture rate of
exosomes greater than 90 percent
from a solution using our technology the
the exosomes and the bees are bound
very well for high capture rates
this is a picture of a transmission
electron microscope tem
showing exosomes captured in this
technology again you can see a great
kind of uniformity of material here
you can even see some of these other
exosome
shape types where here we actually have
on the left
three exosomes bound in a in a vesicle
as well
i think next to that is a double a
double exosum as well
but again great uh
great purity of exosomes captured
there's a number of different assays and
tests that you can do with exosomes one
thing that we care about
is the functionality and the viability
of these exosomes once they've been
isolated
if you look at ultracentrification due
to those shear forces and the time
involved
in this case we're able to show that
using our technology
without those shear forces in using our
gentle release capture
capture release technology we actually
have higher cell uptake
so in this case uh dendritic monocytes
in the fluorescent green we can see that
we have significant cell uptake
relative to the gold standard in
isolation
so the clara exo release technology we
developed
our approach and benefits were able to
provide functional exosomes
with subtypes and there's really no
other method today to be able to get to
pure
functional subtyped exosomes that are
isolated from a solution
we're able to reduce noise in isolation
and
increase reproducibility and hopefully
you know our goal is to move the
industry towards standardization
one protocol that gets you the same
results each time every time
regardless of what you're trying to do
additionally
by being based on immunomagnetic bead
technology which has been around for
more than 35 years
and is well understood within laboratory
operations
it's easier to train personnel on how to
do this process versus some of the more
specific exosome
processes that have been used
traditionally
we've been running a lab service for the
last year and this is just an example of
some of the companies we've worked with
that we're able to show you
we're in the process of launching a kit
right now
to allow people researchers like
yourselves in your own labs
to use this technology and we are
working towards a product launch in the
next few months
but with that if you'd like to learn
more
you can go to our website uh and check
us out
we have data there and you're you're
welcome to partake of our lab service if
you don't want to do the work yourself
you can mail us your biological samples
of interest
we can work with virtually any fluid and
it's fast and easy
if you'd like to learn more about the
kit and look at doing the work yourself
you can also sign up for our early
access program
which is ongoing right now today
with that i will uh end this talk i hope
that you've uh
been able to learn about exosomes and
and subtypes and
and why that matters how we define an
exosome and how
uh there's so much variance within
exosomes even within
single cell production there there's
variants and exosomes it's not a
it's not a uniform or homogeneous
situation if you have any interest
in cell uptake one fascinating and the
exciting thing about
exosomes is they are autologous in
nature
um i'm sorry they're allogeneic in
nature they're not autologous so so you
can actually capture
an exosome from a general cell source
and that generally has no
known toxicity effects in reception by
other
other cells and other bodies so with
that i'll close it out
thank you for your time and enjoy the
rest of the conference